foreign
[Music]
Jacobs I've been making and repairing
hats for about three plus years today
I'll be repairing a hat that is
approximately 70 plus years old while
maintaining its character
[Music]
first I'm going to deconstruct the Hat
it was a seam ripper and then we use
snippers
the felt is in really great condition
but we have to be very careful to make
sure that we don't poke any holes into
the felt or rip something that need to
be ripped
this hat belonged to my client's
grandfather and when he passed he passed
it down to his father we're going to
maintain the character and patina of the
hat and the whole
the client would like to keep the hold
to maintain the continuity from
generation to generation the Hat has a
story and he wants to tell that story as
he wears it
[Music]
next I'm going to clean the filter
I use a little bit of alcohol and a
little bit of water and then we use a
hat brush to brush away any debris that
may be present on the surface of the
felt
so the alcohol does two things it
dissolves a little bit of the bio resin
that's inside of the felt making a
little bit more pliable and more easy to
work with and then it gets rid of any
bacteria that may be present on the
surface of the film and likewise any
mold that may be present
and then we use the sponge to get a
little bit deeper into the fill
[Music]
for the hat band we spray it with
alcohol again and this allows me to go
over it with another sponge to really
sort of clean up the hat band and the
loose threads we really work to keep it
in its original condition we want it
like the felt to maintain the character
that it has gained over those years of
wear
after we do that we take snippers and we
snip any loose threads then we turn our
attention to re-blocking the felt
re-blocking is the most crucial part of
remaking a hat we take the felt and we
heat it up with some steam and then we
stretch it over a block
we are choosing a block that will give
us the circumference of the client's
head
what we're doing here is creating the
basic shape that we want to give the Hat
it's called an open crown
and then once we have it stretched over
the block we'll grab a Hatter's knot and
a pusher Downer which is the tool that
we use to take the Hatters knot to the
bottom of the Hat block
here is where we are creating the 90
degree brake angle between the crown and
the fill
[Music]
the high will be irreparable if the felt
itself was starting to disintegrate
particularly around the brake line that
would create an issue for re-blocking
the Hat
I'm using a brim cutter and it allows
for us to decide how wide or how short
we want the brim this brim has to be
regulated down
a half an inch the general shape will
stay the same but we are making sure
that the Hat frames my client's face
nicely
[Music]
and then I'll use a fine grit sandpaper
to really refine the edge
[Music]
in the brim cutting process you don't
always get the cleanest Edge so the
Sandpaper allows for us to really create
sharp edges on the hats
[Music]
and finally we will create a Sweat Band
we cannot reuse the old Sweat Band all
we have left is the Reed and so we have
to replace the Sweat Band with a new
piece of leather the sweatband is
critically important to maintaining the
Integrity of the Hat it really holds the
Hat together but more importantly it
allows for a barrier between the
wearer's forehead and the felt itself
Hatters can do a lot of things but
getting sweat out of field is quite a
difficult fee
and then finally we shape the crown of
the Hat
we use steam again steam really allows
for the felt fibers to open up their two
material components that make up the
felt there's the individual fur fibers
and then there is the bio red built
without the bio resin would be very
flimsy and not have very much structure
to it we are really opening that up and
softening it a bit so that we can get
the desired shape
[Music]
I'm excited about this particular
restoration and I think that my client
will be over the moon and Overjoyed but
he has a hat that looks and feels like
his grandfather's hat and also has the
patina and the character that comes with
a 70 plus year old hat the only reason
this hat would need to be brought back
into our shop as if we need to do hat
maintenance particularly with the Sweat
Band in general this hat will last as
long as my client wants to wear the hat
[Music]